[Music]
braces hurt and it's no wonder your
teeth aren't supposed to move like that
but there's more happening here than
meets the eye
braces don't work the way you probably
think because they don't just shift your
teeth around they have to break down
your jawbone first Americans pay up to
$7,500 for braces per person but it's
worth it
and not just for that perfect Instagram
will smile you see misaligned teeth are
tricky to clean increasing your risk of
tooth decay gum disease or even to
Schloss that's where braces can help
straighten out the problem but moving
teeth is no easy feat because there's
something in the way your jawbone now
the orthodontist doesn't take out a
drill and break your jaw themselves
instead they trick your body into doing
the hard work for them
that's where braces come in the wires
are tightened across your teeth in order
to create pressure against your gums in
turn that pressure constricts blood flow
to the tissue that holds your teeth in
place sort of like squeezing a hose to
stop the water and without blood the
tissue cells start to die now normally
that would be a major problem because
without that supportive tissue your
teeth could fall out but in this case
that's exactly what the doctor or
dentist ordered because your immune
system rushes to the rescue sending in
special cells called osteoclasts
which ultimately relieves the pressure
and restore blood flow they do this by
sucking away the calcium from your
jawbone yep
the cells are literally dissolving your
bone it may sound like an extreme
solution to the problem but the result
is a nice hole in your jaw bone where
the tooth can move in away from the
wires and all that pressure ultimately
restoring blood flow so that the tissue
stays alive and your teeth don't fall
out
but you don't just do all of this once
people with braces have to check in with
their orthodontist regularly because
they need their braces retighten so more
teeth can move into place and the more
teeth you have to move the longer the
braces will be on typically it takes
months to a couple years to get the job
done but eventually the ordeal ends the
braces come off for good and you can
enjoy your new smile
[Music]